[Music]
chuck i want to tell you about how your
brain is wired
uh poorly would be the answer
okay like a like a house with
with a bad
[Laughter]
yeah scotch tape all right right so
it's not how just your brain is why just
the human brain
all right so we evolved on you know the
planes of the serengeti not literally
but that's
close enough for this example where you
know something's chasing you
you and it might harm you you want to
run away from it
right it gets closer you go up a tree
whatever there's certain
um challenges that we face that require
certain solutions
and in almost every case the solution
involves linear thinking okay
linear thinking okay that's it so which
is uh
and by that you mean sequential right so
well it's not
yeah so linear i'm using very loosely
here but sequential thinking
so i'll give an example so the tiger is
running towards you
right or the lion right this would be
africa so the line is running towards
you
well the first thing you say i don't
know how you say
oh sh in af
and whatever african swahili that's why
how do you say oh crap in sweden i don't
know
right so so the line is chasing after
you
and it closed half the distance to you
in about 10 seconds let's say okay
so you do a calculation in your head say
if i don't get completely out of range
of the line in another 10 seconds
i am lunch okay yeah okay okay all right
so
that's the kind of calculations we do
the line is not a hundred meters away
and then in the next second one meter
away from you
that's different thinking right right if
that were actually happened to us we'd
have a whole other kind of brain wiring
but everything that happens around us
happens in these increments which when
you add up the increments
leads to what happens next okay so the
conclusion that we're trying to
promote or or avoid so linear thinking
is it did this much in this amount of
time
it'll do a little bit more and more time
right and a little bit more
and this is how you construct your
interaction with the world
right okay that makes sense we have
hardly any experience
thinking exponentially about the world
okay
hardly any okay so you can think but
let's
let's give some other examples you can
think back to your grandparents all
right you surely met them or knew them
probably not your great-grandparents i
knew mine oh you did you so you knew
them
they lived alone they lived a very long
time my great-grandmother
lived a very long time your grandfather
i think she killed him
okay but she was still here
i don't know why that's even plausible
you know it's like
yeah you can picture that right
[Laughter]
um she killed her but she's otherwise
doing fine right well other than that
she was great
and what's she doing now oh six to ten
and right
exactly so so uh the point is if i now
say
uh all right so that was like 50 100 150
years ago
now imagine a million years ago no you
can't
there's no way to do that there's no in
fact we weren't humans then
for that matter okay so so so many
things that
range in size greater than just the
factors of a few
are very hard for the human brain to
comprehend
and i put this all under the challenge
of what it is to appreciate exponentials
all right you can go from one to two to
three to four to five in astrophysics we
go from one to ten
to a hundred to a thousand to ten
thousand
okay and the ten thousand is ten
thousand times larger than the one
right but if you're just counting one
two three four five five is only
five times bigger than one so
this so when you're in the world of
exponentials
oh my gosh so what it takes to sort of
wrap your head around it
and understand it so earth is big to
most people
it's so big to flat earthers they think
the round earth is flat
so if you hollowed out the sun
you could pour more than a million
earths
inside of it that's insane and still a
million
and still have room not ten not a
thousand not ten thousand not a hundred
a million all right now the sun will one
day become a red giant
right and it'll expand and engulf the
orbits of mercury venus
and and be on the doorsteps of the earth
okay
that sun if you hollow that out
could fit a million of the suns that we
started with
oh lord okay so so in astrophysics we
confront this
daily not only in size but in
temperature in time
or all these things scale i'm going to
be honest right now
yeah i'm still trying to conceive of a
million
earths inside of the the
white yellow ball that i look up and see
in the sky
immediately because that i'm gonna i'm
i don't i hope this doesn't make me
stupid
[Music]
but the truck trying to start any
sentence with that
just just
right no but i'm i can't because
it's like saying i'm not racist but you
know
[Laughter]
it's so true whatever comes out of your
mouth next whatever you're gonna be
right is the most racist
thing ever said right you know or i
don't mean any offense but
right you in other words listen i'm
about to offend you
okay but i cannot conceive
now i okay so you see these models of
the solar system
and you you see the sun in the middle
you can't draw it the proper size but
you can't draw at the proper size
and so now my brain as i'm trying to
conceive of the actual
size of the sun unfortunately
i am thwarted by the parameters that
have been
set for me psychologically by these
stupid models
that i've seen interfering right right
so they do interfere
that that's right because if you showed
the sun
sort of large enough to see in the
middle of the solar system this the
earth would be too small
you're right you couldn't see the earth
you wouldn't see the earth or the moon
or mercury or venus you'd see jupiter
be a little bigger but so you exaggerate
the sizes of the planets
but at that size if you show the sun at
its real size it would be really huge
and then you couldn't fit it all on the
same page
because the distances are also uh
exponentially separated
so so so these are the challenges that
you face but as an astrophysicist we are
we're steeped in it we are baptized in
it and so we have a
slightly better facility thinking this
way
than most everybody else that doesn't
have to confront it in everyday life
okay so here's here are examples of how
this can mess with you and i think
you're smart enough you might get the
right answer to this
so if you discover an algae growing on a
lake
right and you learn that the algae sort
of
doubles in the area because algae is all
about how much area
it doubles every day okay every day
there's twice as much algae as the
previous day
okay so you hear that this algae is like
attacking the lake
and and it began a month ago
30 days 30 days ago and you go there and
you see that
half the lake is covered with algae so
it took an entire month
to cover that half okay so then the
question is
how long will it take to cover the rest
of the lake
that's the question okay so it took an
entire month to cover
half the lake correct okay
so then that means then
oh no but it's doubling
so that means and it's doubling that
means it's going to double the next day
and that means the next day from that
it's going to double again and that
means the next day from that
it's going to double again so no i think
to cover the whole lake maybe at two
days one day
okay there you go don't get too excited
chuck
that's what i said you know what i said
i said one day right
you went through one day and got the two
days yeah so the
the linear brain is saying oh it'll take
another month right but the exponential
brain says it's doubling every day
in fact it didn't matter how long it
took
to cover half the lake right if it's
doubling every day right it takes
only one more day to cover the entire
life oh my god and
in 10 days it'll cover the earth yeah
right so it's two to the tenth power
and you do the numbers i got another one
for you right so
chuck i can hand you five million
dollars right now
i'll tell you more thank you thank you
very much
i always knew i liked you
okay or i can give you
a penny a day
but doubled every day for 30 days
no i'm going to take the penny yeah so
you know now see i see i'm training
because we just listen
we just did it we just did it with algae
you know damn well i'm not gonna do it
with money
we just did this with algae now we're
doing it with money
oh no give me you're taking the money
so if you do this um after on the 31st
day
in a 31 day month i'll be handing you 10
million dollars
nice now but i've been handing you money
every day up until then right
add all that up it's basically the same
amount as the amount i'm giving you on
the 31st day
so you walk away with 20 million dollars
not 5 million that's amazing
so now okay so now uh an exponential
means you have some number in the
exponent
of another number and you raise it to
that power right this is how you
calculate
interest rates on mortgages
okay tell me about it okay it is
time raised to some power and it's a
factor
on your monthly payments if you have a
floating
mortgage rate which floats with
the moving interest rates that can have
a
devastating effect on your monthly
payments and your total debt
yes had people been fluent
in exponentials in 2008
they could have said when the bank says
approved
you'll say wait a minute uh i'm gonna go
with a 30-year fix not that interest
only
yeah exactly i'm going 30-year fix
because i can calculate with the
exponential and plus you i realize
you're exploiting me now
right so so how much of that 2008
collapse of the real estate market and
the rest of the economy
might have been avoided had people been
fluent in thinking about the effects of
raising numbers to the powers of other
numbers
wow and that is the ex that's an
exponential for you
that is first of all let me just say
this
two things one i need somebody to
start off with a penny and give me
double that every day for 30 days that's
the first thing i took from this
the second thing i took from this is i
need to call a mortgage broker
right now
that's the one knocking on your door
right now right right
so there's much more about exponentials
we could talk about but i'm just saying
you get the gist of it right
yeah and and when when things increase
it's why people have a hard time
understanding the power of
time over that much time right so so you
say well
the grand canyon how did that happen you
can't well give it enough time
not hundreds of years not even thousands
but millions of years millions
yeah and you think you understand a
million
but you don't if you think it's just a
little bit bigger than a thousand
right no it's a factor of a thousand
bigger than a thousand
right we went from from
our mammal shrew rodent-like ancestors
running under foot of t-rex 65 million
years ago
to the entire
presence of mammals in the world
including the
the primates including humans in 65
million years
all right that is even small compared
with the time life has been on earth
but it's way bigger than most people can
wrap their head around
and see the only mistake in all that
time was human beings
everybody everything else was running
everything else was running smooth man
and we had to come along
and mess it all up
so the people say that could never
happen how do you go from a reptile to
of this or how do you go from a bird
to this these are people whose brain
wiring
is linear and so they cannot possibly
see the full
effects of the depths of time it's so
exciting
depths of space to this and and
basically we're hopeless that's why in
one of my books the astrophysics for
people in a hurry you know how i began
that book with the one one sentence you
know what the opening sentence was
uh i forget but i didn't know that's
polite of you
i never read the book i never brought
the word
i once knew but okay my opened if i say
the universe is under no obligation
to make sense to you that's correct
that's very cool
and that includes exponentials yes
somebody took that and made a t-shirt
out of it i hope you're getting paid on
it
seriously i saw that as a t-shirt you
saw it okay i saw that at a t-shirt i
hope you're getting paid
well there's a new saying now you can't
say everything's big in texas
everything's big in astrophysics texas
you lose
everything's big in astrophysics that's
all there is to it well my wife is from
alaska
and you can carve alaska five times and
get five different texases
so wow in terms of who's the biggest
state uh
that's how that how that plays out there
you go
anyhow chuck we got to call it quits
there all right all right this stuff
good stuff
good stuff another uh explainer video
this one on exponentials
neil degrasse tyson keep looking up
[Music]
you